Hi, welcome back to this my final
session on growth investing. Let's
review where we are. We started with an
introductory session where we looked at
small cap investing as one strand of
growth investing. We then turned to
IPOs, initial public offerings and then
to screening for young growth companies
and in the last session activist growth
investing in the form of venture
capitalists. This one I' I'd like to
pull all the strands together and talk
about growth investing in the aggregate
because in many ways growth investing it
looks like you're going against the tide
of history. And in a minute I'll show
you a graph that illustrates what I'm
talking about and it looks like you're
winning against the odds. So let's set
the table by looking at why so many
investors call themselves value
investors rather than growth investors.
You can trace it back to this one chart.
What is this chart? It looks at returns
on an annual basis for stocks classified
based on PE ratios from lowest to
highest. And if you remember,
we used to back up value investing that
the lowest PE stocks earn much higher
returns than the highest PE stocks. And
that this has been true for a century.
That's the legend of value investing. In
many ways, when you pick growth
investing, people's response is, why
would you do that? the highest P stocks
which tend to often have the highest
growth rates have underperformed.
There are four ways you can push back if
you are an advocate for growth
investing. The first is while it is true
that over this entire time period
outperform growth investing at least in
its most generic form low PE stocks beat
high PE stocks. If you look on a
year-to-year basis, you see that there
are periods of time, sometimes extended
periods, where high PE stocks
outperformed low PE stocks. So,
basically what you have in this graph is
a difference in growth in value over
time. And it's a function of earnings
growth. During periods where earnings
growth is low, it turns out that growth
stocks do much better. That might strike
you as contradictory, but here's the
rationale. When earnings growth in the
aggregate is low, growth becomes a
scarce resource. So you are willing to
pay a higher price for growth stocks. So
the first thing that seems to drive this
yearto-year shift is what the actual
growth rate is. In periods when growth
is high in the aggregate, value
investing outperforms. In periods where
people are struggling to grow overall
aggregate growth is low, growth
investing wins out. The second thing
that seems to affect growth investing is
what the yield curve is doing. The yield
curve of course captures the difference
between the short-term rates and
long-term rates. In most time periods,
long-term rates are higher than
short-term rates. The yield curve is
upward sloping. But when the yield curve
is flat, short-term rates are similar to
long-term rates or downward sloping. It
turns out that growth investing
outperforms value investing which
actually
described because when the yield curve
is flat or downward sloping you're
looking at recessions negative growth.
So the key variable that seems to drive
growth investing is can you time the
economy and the overall know patterns of
growth in the economy. There's a
component of market timing that seems to
kick in with growth investing. And
finally, if you are a growth investor,
you can also point to recent history.
This table goes only through 2018, but I
did in a previous session look at the
table all the way through 2024.
The payoff to growth investing, at least
in terms of low PE versus high PE
stocks, seems to become more in growth
investing's favor in this century. This
century, high PE stocks have actually
matched up to or even outperform low PE
stocks. So let's summarize what your
case might be for growth investing. One
is when earnings growth is low, growth
investing seems to win. So maybe that's
the time you go into growth investing.
Second, when the yield curve is flat or
downward sloping periods where you're
heading into recession or low economic
growth, growth investing seems to win.
Again, a potential winner.
And the third is there's this timing
issue. As over time, as you've gone
through, you know, you see that the
payoff to buying high PE stocks has
become better. You think that's three,
you said four. Here's the fourth one.
Ultimately, when we talked about active
investing, we're not just buying low PE
stocks or high PE stocks. Were picking
individual stocks. And there is
evidence, though it's it's contested
that the payoff to active investing.
Picking stocks is greater if you're a
growth investor than a value investor.
Very old study. Bert Malcio, you know,
illustrated this by by by doing a very
clever exercise. He took the average
actively managed value fund and the
average actively managed growth fund.
And the average actively managed value
fund outperformed the average actively
managed growth fund by.16%.
You're saying that means value funds are
better, right? But wait, he showed that
if you bought a value index fund, which
is basically low P stocks in the
aggregate and and a growth index fund,
that the value index fund outperformed
the growth index fund by 47%. You're
saying where is this going? If you think
about the difference between those two
numbers, which is 31 basis points or
31%, you could argue that that's the
payoff that active growth managers get
relative to value managers. Because
remember, remember if they both pick
stocks the same way. The difference
between the two should be 47% in both
the index fund and with the active
investors. But you don't get that. There
is some evidence that stock picking has
a much bigger payoff when you're a
growth investor than a value investor.
Now, if you ask me why that might be,
there are three things that I think
explain the phenomenon. First is the
kinds of companies that growth investors
scrutinize tend to be smaller. They're
less followed. You could argue that the
payoff to doing research is greater with
small companies and less followed
companies with large mature companies.
Second, small companies know or growth
companies are more difficult to value
than mature companies. As somebody who
teaches valuation, I know this for a
fact. You think that must mean the
payoff is great at the value mature
companies, right? No. Because if mature
companies are easy to value, they're
easy to value not just to you, but to
everybody else. The payation
is greater when you have difficult to
value companies. You can argue that
growth companies are more difficult to
value. more estimates to make, more
judgments to make, less trust on
historical data. And finally, there's an
argument to be made that with small
growth companies, there is a payoff to
knowing the business they're in. If you
truly understand medicine and drugs and
pharmaceuticals, you might have an
advantage with a small biotech company
that you will not have with a large
steel company. So active growth
investing seems to do better in the
numbers and there is a rationale for why
it works better and of course you got to
walk in with open eyes. There are
pitfalls in growth investing and there
are three big ones. One is what I call
the scaling problem. Many companies when
you invest in them as growth companies
are small and young and if you're right
they will become larger. You're saying
so what as you scale up it turns out
that it becomes much more difficult to
grow. Second, growth by itself is not a
good thing and you can pay too much for
growth. So you got to answer the
question not just how much the growth is
but how valuable is it and how
sustainable is it. And third there is a
component of momentum in growth
investing. You saw that with the cycles.
It becomes critical that you get in at
the right time and get out at the right
time. There is a momentum trading
component to growth investing that might
lead investors to earn higher returns.
So, let's take each of these factors.
Let's start with the scaling factor. To
back up my scaling argument, I'm going
to look back at a study of IPOs. And
what the study looked at was companies
that are going public. And it looked at
the revenue growth rate of these
companies a year after they went public
and then two years after, three years.
So, you're creating a portfolio of
companies that go public and you track
their growth rates relative to the
revenue growth rates of the sector.
Let's start with the good news. When you
buy these companies after they go
public, remember they go public at the
peak of their growth. Their revenue
growth rate is 15% higher than the
revenue growth rate of the sector
they're in. That's good, right? Two
years later, same companies, the revenue
growth rate is only about 7 to 8%
higher. 3 years later, it's 3% higher.
By the time you get to year five, the
growth has faded. In most companies,
growth fades as companies scale up for
two reasons. One is as you get bigger
that same percentage growth rate becomes
tougher to maintain. It's one thing to
grow your revenues at 10% of your
revenues of 100 million. Entirely
different game when you have a billion.
Second, as you grow, you attract
competition that competition goes after
the same growth. Scaling up is hard to
do. Something you got to remind yourself
if you're a growth company investing in
small growth companies.
Second, there is this very lazy view
that growth is a good thing at
companies. In fact, many analysts
growing. But remember, growth has those
two effects we talked about in the
context of the valuation session. The
good effect is it makes your revenues
and earnings higher. The bad is you got
to reinvest to deliver that growth in
what in factories and R&D and whatever
you need to reinvest to grow. The net
effect of growth will depend on which
effect dominates.
One simplistic rule you can use is if
you earn more than your cost of capital,
growth will add value. If you earn
roughly your cost of capital, growth
will do nothing for value. If you earn
less than your cost of capital, you will
destroy value as you grow. You'll
actually be better off not growing. So
every year at the start of the year, I
go through an exercise where I compute
the return on capital for every publicly
traded company in the world. I compute
the cost of capital for every publicly
traded company in the world and I
compare the two. What I'm trying to get
a sense of is what percentage of
companies globally generate more than
their cost to capital and therefore add
value when they grow. If you look across
all publicly traded firms, the the
statistics are truly scary. Across all
global companies which are publicly
traded, 29%
earn a return on capital that exceeds
their cost of capital. 29%. That's a
nice way of saying 71% earn less than
the cost of capital. Some have good
reasons, right? They're young companies.
They have a tough year. But that number
basically suggested you got to be
skeptical about growth. Even if you
focus in just on money-making companies,
which is a very, very low threshold for
success, are you making money? 46% of
companies earn more than their cost of
capital. 54% earn less than the cost of
capital. Most companies as they grow
have trouble delivering value from that
growth.
Now if on top of that you add how
sustainable is this growth that becomes
a question of what are your competitive
advantages. In the words of Warren
Buffett what is your moat in a in a
strange way when value investors spend a
lot of time on moes with mature
companies the real place or the real
group of companies where you care about
modes is growth companies.
And there in this table I've actually
tried to list out different types of
competitive advantage and varants where
the mode is wide. These are most
sustainable to no mode. Let's take brand
name. Every company claims to have a
brand name right? If you truly have a
top brand that's a wide mode it's very
difficult to replicate. If you just have
a name brand people recognize your name
it's a narrow mode. I mean that
recognition might by itself might not
give you much. If you have a generic
brand there's no mode. Switching cost.
That's a cost of switching into your
product as low as possible. Cost of
switching out as high as possible. If
the cost of switching out of your pro of
your product is infinite, you have a
wide mode. If there are no costs, you
have no mode. Networking benefits
capture the fact that if you succeed as
a company, sometimes it gets easier for
you to succeed. That's what networking
benefits capture. If your networking
benefits are global, what that means is
as you get bigger, you you it gives you
an advantage everywhere in the world,
then you have a very wide mode. If you
have local networking benefits just in
your city or town, then the mode is
narrower. And if you have no networking
benefits, it's no mode at all. If you
have permanent cost advantages, a Ramco
has permanent cost advantages in the oil
business because it can extract oil at
such a low cost. That's a very wide
mode. But if you have temporary cost
advantages, you manage to build a
factory in a low labor local, that's
temporary because somebody else can do
exactly what you it's. It's a narrower
mode. No cost advantages. There's no
mode. If you have full legal protection,
nobody can do what you do. Maybe because
you are given a monopoly by the
government. That's a wide mode. If you
have partial legal protection, some
things can be protected by the others
and the mode gets narrower.
No legal protection, there's no mode.
And it plays out in your valuation in
how you think about these companies. So
it's not just growth, but thinking about
how sustainable that growth is and how
valuable that growth is. Which brings me
to the final component, which is all
growth investing seems to have a
momentum component. In momentum markets,
when momentum is driving things, growth
stocks tend to do well. So if you are
good at detecting shifts in momentum, it
can carry over into growth investing.
The caveat though, you can play the
momentum game. And many growth investors
forget they're playing the momentum game
and they fool themselves into believing
that they're making money because
they're valuing growth companies well.
In fact, they're riding momentum. Be
honest with yourself.
So if you decide to become a growth
investor, be proud to call yourself a
growth investor,
don't go around, you know, calling
yourself value because that's a value
investor just because that's what
everybody else is doing, but be clear
about what kind of growth investor you
are and what makes you good at that
component of investing.
Now there the notion that growth
investors don't care about value is
absolutely false. Good growth investors
care about value. Take a look at Peter
Lynch's record and his books. Clearly,
the man cares about value. And you could
argue that in growth investing, your
odds improve because you're bringing
more to the table than a mature than
value investors are doing with mature
companies. As we enter the day of the
age of AI and chat GPT, you could argue
that that differential advantage you
bring because there's something you
bring to the table with growth investors
that other people don't don't bring
that's giving you those excess returns
that should actually get greater as we
mechanize this process and data becomes
more available.
I hope you succeed as a growth investor
if that's what you choose to do. And I
hope you found these sessions on growth
investing useful in doing that. Thank
you very much for listening.